Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. I'm joined by Dr. Benjamin Carney, a professor of social psychology at the University of California, Los Angeles, and co-director of the UCLA Marriage Lab. Dr. Carney is a leading scholar of social relationships and marriage who studies change and stability in intimate relationships with a particular. emphasis on minority populations, including low-income couples and military families. Welcome, Dr. Carney. Oh, thanks for having me. Happy to have you here today. So you're a co-author of a study that was recently published by the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology that examined what's known as Demand-Witrae behavior. And so to summarize that, that means one partner in a relationship asks the other to change something, and the partner who's asked to make that change basically shuts
你好，欢迎收听《心理学对话》，这是一档由美国心理协会制作的播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。今天做客我们节目的是加利福尼亚大学洛杉矶分校社会心理学教授、UCLA婚姻实验室的联合主任本杰明·卡尼博士。卡尼博士是社会关系和婚姻领域的顶尖学者，他主要研究亲密关系中的变化与稳定性，并特别关注少数群体，包括低收入伴侣和军人家庭。欢迎你，卡尼博士。哦，谢谢邀请我来。很高兴今天能来到这里。那么，你是最近发表在《个性与社会心理学期刊》上的一项研究的共同作者，该研究探讨了所谓的“要求-撤退”行为。简而言之，这意味着关系中的一方要求另一方改变某些事情，而那个被要求做出改变的伴侣基本上会选择关闭
down and withdraws. And in this study, you looked at how that behavior is impacted based, impacts the couple's relationship satisfaction based on their income levels. So what did, can you explain what you found? Sure. What we're building off of is an existing literature on the negative implications of the demand withdrawal pattern. So there's been a lot of research on marriage that shows that when one partner seeks change and the other partner is inventing, in the status quo, you get this negative cycle where the person who wants change has to turn up the volume and ask more and ask more. And the person who loves the status quo, which is often the male partner, but not always, has to withdraw to maintain the status quo. And then that means that the
自己并进行撤退。在这项研究中，你们探讨了这种行为如何受到影响，以及如何根据夫妻的收入水平影响他们的关系满意度。那么，你们发现了什么？你能解释一下吗？当然。我们的研究建立在关于“要求-撤退”模式的负面影响的现有文献基础之上。关于婚姻的研究有很多，表明当一方寻求改变而另一方墨守成规时，就会陷入一种负面循环：希望改变的人不得不提高音量，提出更多、更多的要求；而喜欢现状的人（通常是男性伴侣，但也不全是）则必须撤退来维持现状。这就意味着
person who wants change has to get louder and louder. The person who withdraws has to get worse and worse. And a lot of research that's been done shows that this pattern has negative implications for marriage. But couples that fall into this sort of negative cycle of demanding and withdrawing, experience lower marital satisfaction, experience declines of marital satisfaction, experience higher rates of divorce. So that's the conventional wisdom. The limits, the problem with that conventional wisdom is that all of that research,
希望改变的人声音必须越来越大，而撤退的人则必须表现得越来越糟。许多已经完成的研究表明，这种模式对婚姻具有消极影响。陷入这种要求与撤退的负面循环的夫妻，其婚姻满意度较低，婚姻满意度会出现下降，离婚率也会更高。这就是传统观念。这种传统观念的问题在于，所有这些研究，
and I mean all of it, has been conducted on middle class or more affluent, mostly white, college-educated couples. Okay. So the advice that's available for all couples is based on research on a very narrow range of couples. And the assumption is, well, demand withdrawal is going to be equally bad for everybody. So it doesn't matter that we actually have never studied it in anyone except for a bunch of college-educated white couples. Our work questions that assumption and says, well, wait a minute. What if we think about couples that are not affluent that we're not affluent that we're not,
我是指所有的研究，都是在中产阶级或更富裕、主要是白人且受过大学教育的夫妻身上进行的。好吧。因此，针对所有夫妻的建议都是基于对极少数特定群体的研究。而且人们默认：嗯，“要求-撤退”对每个人来说都是同样糟糕的。所以，除了这群受过大学教育的白人夫妻之外，我们从未在其他人身上研究过它，这并不重要。我们的工作对这一假设提出了质疑，并指出：等一下。如果我们考虑那些并不富裕的夫妻，那些我们没有考虑过的、可能没有富裕且受过大学教育的夫妻所拥有的那种选择的夫妻呢？
might not have gone to college, that might not have the same options that affluent college-educated couples have. What were the implications of that cycle in that other context? And what we were thinking is that what makes demand withdrawal so negative for affluent couples is the presumption, the implicit assumption that people can change things if they want to in their lives. So if I'm asking you for change. I'm saying, you could change if you wanted to. And so you're not wanting to, you're not changing means you don't want to, which means a baby, you don't love me, you don't care about me. Right. In non-affluent couples, in couples that might be poor or disadvantaged, that assumption isn't true. You can't assume that people who don't change would,
在这种其他背景下，该循环的影响是什么？我们的想法是，让“要求-撤退”对富裕夫妻产生如此消极影响的原因，是一种假设，即隐性假设：如果人们想在生活中改变某些事情，他们就能改变。所以，如果我要求你改变，我的意思是：如果你想的话，你是可以改变的。因此，你不想改变、你不去改变，就意味着你不想这样做，也就是或许你不爱我，你不在乎我。好吧。对于非富裕夫妻、可能贫穷或处于不利地位的夫妻来说，这种假设并不成立。你不能假设那些不改变的人之所以
don't change because they don't want to change. Couples that don't have resources might not be able to change. So let's say I'm a spouse and I'm asking my partner hey, you know, you should make more money. You should get a better job. You should work harder for this family. Well, if I'm an affluent couple, I'm like, well, your failure
不改变，是因为他们不想改变。缺乏资源的夫妻可能根本无法改变。假设我是一个伴侣，我在要求我的另一半：“嘿，你知道的，你应该赚更多的钱。你应该找一份更好的工作。你应该为这个家庭更加努力地工作。”好吧，如果我身处一个富裕的伴侣关系中，我就会想：“嗯，你未能
to do so means you don't care enough. But if I'm a poor couple, your failure to do so might mean that you can't. I might be asking you for something that you cannot do. So for a poor couple, withdrawing in the face of that kind of demand might actually be adaptive.
做到这一点，意味着你不够在乎。”但如果我身处一个贫穷的伴侣关系中，你未能做到这一点可能意味着你做不到。我可能在向你提出你根本无法办到的要求。因此，对一对贫穷的夫妻来说，面对这种要求时选择撤退，实际上可能是具有适应性的。
that was the idea. An adaptive meaning it's... It might actually help the relationship. That that might be the best available way of dealing with your demand would be to withdraw because I can't address it any other way. Okay. So we tested it. We were one of the, I think the first study ever that got a diverse set of couples and
这就是当时的想法。适应性意味着它……实际上可能有助于改善这段关系。面对你的要求，最好的处理方式可能就是撤退，因为我无法用其他任何方式来应对它。好的。所以我们对其进行了测试。我认为我们是第一项将各种不同的夫妻群体聚集在一起，并
actually used observational data on poor and affluent couples. Most observational research on marriage took place only with the affluent couples. But we had a diverse, we went out of our way to sample couples in low-income neighborhoods and couples that were more affluent. So we had a range of couples. We videotape talking about problems. And we identified the demand withdrawal pattern. And here's what we showed.
在穷人和富裕夫妻身上实际使用观察数据的研究。大多数关于婚姻的观察研究都仅限于富裕夫妻。但我们拥有一组多元化的研究对象，我们特意在低收入社区和更富裕的社区抽样调查了不同的夫妻。所以我们拥有各种各样的夫妻。我们把他们关于解决问题的对话录了下来，并识别出了“要求-撤退”的模式。以下是我们的发现。
We showed this in two different samples that the couples who were more affluent, the more did this demand withdrawal cycle, the worse off they were. But the couples who were less affluent, the more that did demand withdraw, the better off they were. Demand withdraw that every advice column says, don't do this. You know, don't allow yourself to fall into the cycle. That advice would have been bad advice for the low-income couples.
我们在两个不同的样本中展示了这一点：越是富裕的夫妻，越是表现出这种“要求-撤退”的循环，他们的状况就越糟糕；但越是不富裕的夫妻，越是表现出“要求-撤退”，他们的状况反而越好。每个建议专栏都在说“不要这样做”的“要求-撤退”模式，你知道的，不要让自己陷入这个循环。对于低收入夫妻来说，这样的建议其实是糟糕的建议。
The poorest couples in our sample actually benefited from engaging in a demand-withdraw pattern. And so that's the news here. And the broader lesson is the advice that we give to couples has to be tailored to their circumstances. The same advice that applies to couples that have a lot of resources might not apply. It might even be counterproductive for couples that don't have a lot of resources. And that's what we found. And a lot of your research, as I mentioned, when I was introducing you, does include minority populations, I would say,
我们样本中最贫困的夫妻，实际上通过参与“要求-撤退”的模式而受益了。这就是这里的新发现。更广泛的教训是，我们给夫妻的建议必须根据他们的实际情况进行调整。适用于资源丰富的夫妻的建议，可能并不适用于他们。对于缺乏资源的夫妻来说，它甚至可能会适得其反。这就是我们的发现。正如我在介绍你时所提到的，你的很多研究确实包含了少数群体，我想说的是，
and not necessarily racial, ethnic minorities, but income, minorities, military families. So why do you think it's important to include such a diverse sample in your research? Can you explain your commitment to that inclusivity? Absolutely. There's two ways about it. I mean, for me personally, it's a sort of an ideology that says science has not done a good job of representing the broader population or diverse populations. It's easier for a scientist, and I, you know, I have to, I have empathy for social science, which is a hard thing to do, to try to make it a little easier by studying conveniently available samples. Because, boy, science is hard, so at the least I can do is study an easy sample to get. The problem is that the easiest sample to get is white people, is people who hang out around universities who tend to go to college.
不一定是种族和族裔少数群体，而是收入少数群体、军人家庭。那么，你为什么认为在你的研究中纳入如此多样化的样本很重要？你能解释一下你对这种包容性的坚定承诺吗？当然。这可以从两个方面来看。对我个人而言，这是一种意识形态，即科学在代表更广泛的人口或多元化群体方面做得还不够好。对于科学家来说，选择研究那些唾手可得的样本会更容易一些，而且我也对社会科学抱有同理心，这是一件很难做的事，大家会试图通过研究便利样本来让事情变得稍微容易一点。因为，天哪，科学研究太难了，所以我能做的最起码的事情就是去研究一个容易获得的样本。问题是，最容易获得的样本是白人，是那些在大学周围闲逛、往往会上大学的人。
It's a lot of extra expense, an extra effort, if I want to try to find people who are different than that, who are somewhere else. It's only okay to look at convenient samples if the conclusions of that research apply broadly to everybody. Here's the problem. They don't. So my thought is that to be a good scientist, you actually have to directly examine whether, your findings generalized to diverse populations. And now there's a political reason to do this as well, or a policy-based reason, especially for me a family researcher.
如果我想努力寻找那些与此不同、身处其他地方的人，就需要花费大量的额外资金和精力。只有当研究结论能够广泛适用于所有人时，关注便利样本才是可以接受的。问题就在这里：它们并不适用。所以我的想法是，要成为一名优秀的科学家，你实际上必须直接检验你的发现是否能够推广到多元化的人群。现在，这样做还有一个政治原因，或者说基于政策的原因，尤其是对我这样一个家庭研究人员而言。
And this is about 15 years ago, the early 2000s, there were policies put into place by our federal government to try to promote low-income families and promote the health of low-income families. And this was known as the Healthy Marriage Initiative. And it was developed in the second Bush administration to, with a very noble goal, let's help poor families that are struggling. The question is, what kind of help was offered? And the answer is, the help that was offered was help based on the research. Again, very admirable. The only problem is that research had only been conducted on affluent white middle class couples.
大约15年前，也就是2000年代初，我们的联邦政府出台了一些政策，试图扶持低收入家庭并促进低收入家庭的健康。这就是所谓的“健康婚姻倡议”。它是在布什政府第二任期内制定的，带着一个非常崇高的目标：让我们去帮助那些挣扎中的贫穷家庭。问题是，提供了什么样的帮助？答案是：所提供的帮助是基于研究的。同样，这非常值得钦佩。唯一的问题是，那些研究仅仅是在富裕的白人中产阶级夫妻身上进行的。
So millions of dollars, what I mean is hundreds of millions of dollars. What I really mean is almost a billion dollars was spent over the next 10 years on programs to help low-income families based on research on high-income families. You can imagine what the risk is for that, is that the advice and all that money got spent on programs that proved ineffective. So there's real consequences, like a billion dollars worth of consequences of not knowing what's really going on in the those low-income couples. That is what motivates my commitment to studying the couples that haven't been studied. And going back to the results of that other study, in those low-income couples, is too much withdrawal, demand behavior unhealthy? Did you see how it was prolonged? I believe the study was over 18 months, correct, the period of time? It was. Again, there were two different
因此，数百万美元，我的意思是数亿美元。我真正想说的是，在接下来的10年里，近十亿美元被花在了基于对高收入家庭的研究来帮助低收入家庭的计划上。你可以想象这其中的风险是什么，那就是这些建议和所有的资金都花在了被证明无效的计划上。因此，不了解这些低收入夫妻的真实情况，会产生现实的后果，相当于价值十亿美元的后果。这就是激励我致力于研究那些未被研究过的夫妻的动力。回到另一项研究的结果，在那些低收入夫妻中，过多的撤退、“要求”行为是不健康的吗？你们有没有观察到它是如何长期持续的？我相信这项研究历时18个月，对吗？确实如此。同样，有两组不同的
samples there, and we found the same general pattern in both. We did not see, what you're suggesting is a curvilinear effect, an effect that a little bit of demand-withdraw might be good for those couples, but too much would be bad. We didn't see it, but that doesn't mean it's not there. It just means that one of the things is true
样本，我们在两者中都发现了相同的总体模式。我们没有看到你所暗示的那种曲线效应，即一点点“要求-撤退”可能对这些夫妻有益，但太多就会有害的效应。我们没有看到这一点，但这并不意味着它不存在。这只是意味着其中一件事是真实的，那就是
in that in both of these samples, we were studying younger couples, and it's quite possible that the couples that we're seeing weren't the most distressed couples. It might be that if you're really studying maybe couples that have been together longer, or couples that were,
在这两个样本中，我们研究的都是较年轻的夫妻，而且我们看到的夫妻很有可能并不是那些处于极度痛苦中的夫妻。如果你研究的真的是那些在一起时间更长的夫妻，或者是那些
were really struggling with distress, that at the extremes, demand withdrawal might be bad, or too much withdrawal might be bad for a lot of couples. But we didn't see it. In the younger couples, the couples who were still together, who were moderately satisfied and committed to each other, we saw that a modest level of the demand withdrawal pattern was okay. By the way, to be clear, there's an effect, the way we looked at it, there's an effective of withdrawal. Withdrawal generally isn't a great thing. But withdrawal in the face of demand
真正饱受痛苦折磨的夫妻，那么在极端情况下，“要求-撤退”可能是糟糕的，或者对许多夫妻来说，过多的撤退可能是糟糕的。但我们并没有看到这一点。在较年轻的夫妻中，那些仍然在一起、对彼此适度满意并相互承诺的夫妻中，我们发现适度水平的“要求-撤退”模式是可以接受的。顺便说一句，需要明确的是，确实存在一种影响，从我们看待它的方式来看，撤退本身会产生一种影响。撤退通常不是一件好事。但面对要求时的撤退，
turned out to be an adaptive thing for the low-income couples only. Yeah, sort of giving that partner who is withdrawing a chance like save face, if you will, as you say, maybe not face the reality, the very basic realities they're dealing with. That's beautifully said. That's beautifully said, actually. That in a condition where you cannot, your face of the demand that you cannot meet, withdrawal might be the best of a bad set of options. Think of what the other options are. The other options are disappointing you directly or denying your demand or confronting you or getting mad or getting defensive. If those are your options, withdrawal starts to look better and better.
结果证明，这仅仅对低收入夫妻来说是一件具有适应性的事情。是的，这有点像是给那个正在撤退的伴侣一个“保全面子”的机会（如果你愿意这么说的话），正如你所说，也许不用面对他们正在处理的那些非常基本的现实。这话讲得太好了。事实上，这话讲得真是太好了。在一种你无法、面对你无法满足的要求的情况下，撤退可能是糟糕选项中最不坏的一个。想想其他的选择是什么。其他的选择是直接让你失望、或者拒绝你的要求、或者与你对抗、或者生气、或者进行防御。如果这些是你的选择，撤退看起来就会变得越来越好。
Right. That makes a lot of sense. And you mentioned also, too, in the bottom of the study, you know, at the end of it usually concludes saying where future research could go. And you did note that the future research could possibly be on the same-sex couples or could be on older couples to see how it would play out in different, you know, maybe not necessarily from the UCLA Marriage Lab from other researchers. Exactly. Our habit and our expertise is on the earlier years of marriage. and in the same way that I am very reluctant to generalize to diverse couples from the only from the couples that have been studied, I would be reluctant to generalize from what I know about the early years of marriage to studying the later years of marriage.
没错。这很有道理。你也在研究的末尾提到了，你知道的，在结束时通常会总结未来的研究方向。你确实指出，未来的研究可能针对同性伴侣，或者针对老年伴侣，以了解它在不同的情况下会如何发挥作用，你知道的，也许不一定是由UCLA婚姻实验室来做，而是由其他研究人员来做。确实如此。我们的习惯和专业领域是婚姻的早期阶段，就像我非常不愿意仅仅从已经被研究过的夫妻推广到多元化的夫妻一样，我也同样不愿意将我对婚姻早期阶段的了解推广到对婚姻晚期阶段的研究中。
You could easily imagine that demanding the demands, the meaning of demand and the meaning of withdrawal might evolve over the course of relationship. Couples have been together 25, 30 years. What does it mean to withdraw in the face? of a demand then, if the demand is somebody like, oh, you know, I've heard this hundreds of times and it's not going to change, that my withdrawal might be interpreted differently, it might have different implications. Right.
你可以很容易地想象，提出要求、要求的含义以及撤退的含义，可能会在关系的进程中不断演变。如果夫妻在一起25年、30年了，那么在这种情况下，面对要求选择撤退意味着什么？如果这种要求类似于“哦，你知道的，我已经听过这几百次了，而且它不会改变”，那么我的撤退可能会被不同地解读，它可能会带来不同的影响。没错。
And that's a future direction that we pointed out at that paper. So what can couples, what can couples do with this information? So they have this study saying that, you know, sometimes this behavior is helpful, sometimes it's not helpful, but what can the average person in a relationship reading this, what might they take away from it in their own lives? There are implications of this work for couples, which is, but I think the strongest implications of this work are for policymakers. I think the real audience for this paper isn't couples themselves, but policymakers.
这也是我们在那篇论文中指出的未来方向。那么夫妻们，夫妻们可以从这些信息中做些什么呢？他们看到了这项研究，上面说有时这种行为是有帮助的，有时是没有帮助的，但是身处一段关系中的普通人读到这个，他们能从自己的生活中得到什么启发呢？这项工作对夫妻们有一定的影响，但我认为这项工作最强烈的影响是对决策者而言的。我认为这篇论文真正的受众不是夫妻本身，而是决策者。
Because for too long, policymakers have said, again, admirably, let's find the research and base our policy on the research. Unfortunately, the question they haven't asked is, is there available research that applies to the population we want to target. So policymakers, the audience for this paper is to say to policymakers, you can't assume that a program that might work in an affluent population is going to work in a low-income population. That's really the lesson of this. So the implication is if I, as a policymaker, want to improve or target a particular population,
因为长期以来，决策者们一直表示：同样，值得钦佩的是，“让我们寻找研究，并把我们的政策建立在研究的基础之上”。不幸的是，他们没有提出一个问题：是否存在适用于我们想要针对的人群的现有研究？因此，对于决策者而言，这篇论文的受众在于告诉决策者：你不能假设在一个富裕人群中起作用的计划，在低收入人群中也能起作用。这才是真正的教训。因此，其含义是，如果我作为一名决策者，想要改善或针对特定的人群，
I need to research this explicit of the population because this paper shows that relationships might function quite differently in those two different contexts. So I think that's really the primary audience and the primary value of this paper for making the world a better place, is that we might have hopefully be able to start developing policies that are more targeted and based on more specific research that acknowledges the real differences in the way these intimate relationships, play out at different levels of socioeconomic status. Okay, great. And moving on to your general research with the marriage lab, how do you advise couples to deal with the inevitable conflicts that come up throughout a relationship? So, right, a big issue, and that's just true in all the couples we studied, low income, middle income and high income, is conflict. Now, the way social psychologist, I'm a social psychologist,
我需要对这个具体的人群进行研究，因为这篇论文表明，在不同的背景下，人际关系可能以截然不同 We 的方式运作。所以我认为，这才是这篇论文对于让世界变得更美好而言真正的主要受众和主要价值，那就是我们或许有望开始制定更具针对性的政策，这些政策基于更具体的的研究，并承认这些亲密关系在不同社会经济地位水平下展开时的真实差异。好的，太棒了。接下来谈谈你与婚姻实验室的一般性研究，你如何建议夫妻应对在关系发展过程中不可避免出现的冲突？所以，没错，这是一个重大问题，而且在我们研究的所有夫妻中都是如此：低收入、中等收入和高收入，全都有冲突。现在，社会心理学家（我是一名社会心理学家）
The way social psychologist defined conflict really generally is any time that my pursuit of my goals gets in the way of your pursuit of your goals. So whenever that happens, we've got a conflict. And if you define conflict that way, it follows that conflict's inevitable. It's always going to be conflict. We're always getting each other's way. And the closer we are, the more we get each other's way. Think about, you know, dancing. If the closer we are, the more we're going to separate each other's toes.
对冲突的定义通常非常宽泛：任何时候，我对我的目标的追求妨碍了你对你的目标的追求。每当这种情况发生时，我们就有了冲突。如果你这样定义冲突，那么顺理成章地，冲突就是不可避免的。冲突总是会发生。我们总是在妨碍彼此。而且我们越亲密，我们就越会妨碍彼此。想想看，你知道的，跳舞。如果我们靠得越近，我们踩到对方脚趾的机率就越高。
a good analogy. So the issue in relationships isn't why do we have conflict because conflict's part of the game. We're not going to want the same thing at the same time all the time. We're going to have different desires for when to be on the couch and how often have sex and what do we have for dinner and what time we have kids and all of that. The issue for couples is what do we do what do we do when we hit those conflicts? What do we do when we encounter those conflicts? And our research has talked a lot about what do the what a couples do that makes it makes those couples makes those conflicts easier to manage and what a couples do that makes them harder to manage so and there's a lot on this you know we could go on and on but there's one big issue that's come up
这是一个很好的比喻。所以，关系中的问题并不是“为什么我们会有冲突”，因为冲突是游戏的一部分。我们不可能总是同时想要同一件东西。对于什么时候待在沙发上、多久过一次性生活、晚餐吃什么、什么时候生孩子以及所有这些事情，我们会有不同的渴望。对于夫妻来说，问题在于：当我们遭遇这些冲突时，我们该怎么办？当我们遇到这些冲突时，我们该怎么办？我们的研究探讨了很多关于夫妻怎么做能让这些冲突更容易处理，以及夫妻怎么做会让它们更难处理的内容，所以这方面有很多内容，你知道的，我们可以没完没了地讲下去，但有一个重大问题已经浮出水面
is there are different structures of conflict and we distinguish between vertical conflicts and horizontal conflicts okay what's the difference a vertical conflict is a conflict where one side is objectively right and the other side is objectively wrong. Let me give an example. If you and I start arguing about what the capital of Portugal is, I actually don't know what the capital of Portugal is, but let's assume that we disagreed about it. One of us might be right and the other one would be just wrong. And we could discuss it until we convinced each other, like this is the right answer, that's the wrong answer. Now, the problem with vertical conflicts is that we're almost never in them. our conflicts are not typically vertical conflicts.
那就是存在着不同结构的冲突，我们将冲突区分为了垂直冲突和水平冲突。好的，有什么区别？垂直冲突是指这样一种冲突：其中一方在客观上是正确的，而另一方在客观上是错误的。我举个例子。如果你和我开始争论葡萄牙的首都是哪里（实际上我不知道葡萄牙的首都是哪里，但假设我们在这个问题上意见不一），我们当中可能会有一个人是对的，而另一个人则是完全错的。我们可以讨论它，直到我们说服对方：这就是正确的答案，那是错误的答案。现在，垂直冲突的问题在于，我们几乎从未身处其中。我们的冲突通常不是垂直冲突。
The conflicts that relationship partners have are typically horizontal conflicts. And a horizontal conflict is a difference in values or preferences where there isn't an objectively right or wrong answer where both sides are valid. Here's an example of a horizontal conflict. Let's go to dinner. I want to go to Chinese. You want to go to Italian. Yeah. Okay, that's a conflict.
伴侣之间的冲突通常是水平冲突。水平冲突是指价值观或偏好的差异，并没有客观上的对与错，双方的立场都是合理的。这是一个水平冲突的例子：我们去吃晚餐吧。我想吃中餐。你想吃意大利菜。好吧，这就是一个冲突。
We want different things, but you're not wrong. It's not wrong to one Italian. And it's not like, no, Chinese is just objectively better. It's just we want different things. Right. Almost all conflicts are horizontal conflicts in relationships, but people approach them as if they're vertical conflicts. So if couples disagree in, you know, where should, what religion should we raise our kids? You know, one person's like, well, I, my religion's right and yours is wrong.
我们想要不同的东西，但你并没有错。想吃意大利菜并没有错。也不是说“不，中餐客观上就是更好”。只是我们想要的东西不同。没错。在恋爱关系中，几乎所有的冲突都是水平冲突，但人们对待它们时，却好像它们是垂直冲突一样。因此，如果夫妻在某些事情上有分歧，比如，你知道的，我们应该让孩子信仰什么宗教？你知道的，其中一个人会说，好吧，我，我的宗教是对的，而你的宗教是错的。
And maybe if I, see, if I think that I'm right and you're wrong, or how often do you, how often should we have sex? You know, what's the most appropriate time? Like, well, we should have sex the amount that I want it. And you're wrong to want it your amount. You're like weird, it's for too much or too little. Like, that's wrong. When I think I'm in a vertical conflict, I'm going to try to debate you. I'm going to try to convince you that you're wrong. I'm going to try to instruct you, teach you. None of that works. Yeah, it's not going to get you anywhere. It's not going to get you anywhere. Nobody wants to be convinced by their partner or debated by their partner or instructed by their partner.
也许如果我，你看，如果我认为我是对的，而你是错的，或者我们应该多久发生一次性关系？你知道，最合适的时间是什么时候？就像，好吧，我们应该以我想要的频率发生性关系。而你想按你的频率来，这是不对的。你有点奇怪，要么太多，要么太少。就像，那是不对的。当我认为我处于垂直冲突中时，我会试图与你辩论。我会试图让你相信你是错的。我会试图指导你、教导你。这些全都没用。是的，这不会让你有任何进展。这不会让你有任何进展。没有人愿意被他们的伴侣说服、与伴侣辩论或接受伴侣的指导。
And yet, if I think that there's a right answer and I've got it, that's what it leads me to do. So the advice that we often give couples is, remember that you're in a horizontal conflict. Remember that you can disagree and both sides are still valid. You just want what you want. Your partner wants something different. If you start from there, now you're in a negotiation. If you start from there, you're not in a debate, but you're now in a, just go, okay, you want what you want now we're going to have to talk can we compromise can we take turns it's you still
然而，如果我认为有一个正确答案而且我掌握了这个答案，这就是它导致我去做的事情。因此，我们经常给夫妻的建议是：记住你们处于水平冲突中。记住你们可以存在分歧，并且双方的立场依然是合理的。你只是想要你想要的东西。你的伴侣想要不同的东西。如果你从这里开始，现在你们就在进行谈判。如果你从这里开始，你们不是在进行辩论，而是在说，好吧，你想要你想要的东西，现在我们必须谈谈，我们能妥协吗？我们能轮流来吗？这仍然
might not get what you both want but it feels a lot better to start from a position that both of our positions are valid and that's what thinking about horizontal conflicts does so that's like one thing that couples can do to address the inevitable conflicts that kind of sounds like politics too i guess even that could be really. It's most likely a horizontal conflict and not a vertical con, even though we try to paint it as a vertical conflict. I know we're going off in a different territory, but as soon you said that, that's immediately what I thought of. It's like, is it really one side right or wrong? It's more so different values and how do you compromise? Absolutely. Now, it's a little of the topic of couples and it's not merely, but there are social
可能无法得到你们双方都想要的东西，但从我们双方的立场都是合理的这个基准出发，感觉会好得多，这就是思考水平冲突所能达到的效果。所以这就像是夫妻可以采取的一种做法，来应对不可避免的冲突。这听起来有点像政治，我猜甚至那也真的可能是。它很可能是一个水平冲突，而不是一个垂直冲突，尽管我们试图把它描绘成垂直冲突。我知道我们正走向一个不同的领域，但你一这么说，这就是我脑海中浮现的第一反应。这就像，真的是一方对而另一方错吗？它更多的是关于不同的价值观以及你如何妥协？绝对是的。现在，这稍微偏离了夫妻的话题，不仅如此，还有社会
psychologists who've been studying the deep structure of political conflict. And of course it is a values discussion that the two sides are having. One side says, you know, the most important value is, let's say, equality. And another side says, quality, I'm not against equality, but the most important value is security. Well, you're not wrong to like security. I'm not wrong to value equality. We're just valuing different, we're prioritizing different things. But that's not how it's, that's not how it plays out.
心理学家一直在研究政治冲突的深层结构。当然，这是双方正在进行的一场价值观讨论。一方说，你知道，最重要的价值观是，比方说，平等。而另一方说，平等，我并不反对平等，但最重要的价值观是安全。好吧，你重视安全并没有错。我重视平等也没有错。我们只是在重视不同的事情，我们把不同的事情放在优先位置。但事情并不是这样，事情并不是这样发展的。
in the political realm. It plays out in the political realm. Not that, oh, we want different things. How are we going to negotiate this? It plays out as, I'm right and you are evil Satan. Yeah. The same thing happens in couples, bringing it back. Yeah, bringing back to the relationships.
在政治领域里。在政治领域里，它并不是以“哦，我们想要不同的东西，我们要如何谈判？”这样的方式发展的。它的发展方式是：“我是对的，而你是邪恶的撒旦。”是的。夫妻之间也会发生同样的事情，把话题拉回来。是的，回归到恋爱关系中。
But there's a lot of parallels. I mean, it's human interaction. Absolutely. Express couple, an unhappy couple. They don't just say, oh, we want different things. The unhappy couples say, why do you want? How dare you want what you want? You're wrong.
但这里有很多相似之处。我的意思是，这就是人际互动。绝对是的。一个表现出来的伴侣，一个不快乐的伴侣。他们不会只是说，哦，我们想要不同的东西。不快乐的伴侣会说，你为什么想要？你怎么敢想要你想要的东西？你是错的。
and mean and malevolent for wanting something different than what I want. That is not a road towards compromise. That's not a road towards connection. Thinking about it as a difference of values allows you to say, oh, I'm not going to debate you, I'm not trying to convince you. Let's just negotiate, which always feels better, even though it's still hard. Is this advice you give to couples to how to stay together for the long haul, for a long period of time, is to how to navigate these conflicts?
而且对于想要与我想要的东西不同之物这件事感到卑鄙和恶意。这不是通往妥协的道路。这不是通往连接的道路。把它看作是价值观的差异，能让你说：哦，我不会跟你辩论，我也不是在试图说服你。我们来谈判吧，这总是感觉更好，尽管它仍然很艰难。这是你给夫妻关于如何长久走下去、如何长期维持关系的建议吗，即如何驾驭这些冲突？
to see them in a different light? I mean, yes. Now, generally, my lab is a research lab. I'm a social psychologist, not a clinical psychologist. I'm not really in the advice business. That said, I do do research that I think matters for people and I think has implications for how we live our lives. So, you know, we always give the advice with a very light touch
以不同的眼光看待它们？我的意思是，是的。现在，通常我的实验室是一个研究实验室。我是一名社会心理学家，而不是临床心理学家。我其实不怎么从事提建议的业务。话虽如此，我确实做一些我认为对人们很重要的研究，并且我认为这些研究对我们如何生活具有启示意义。所以，你知道，我们提出建议时总是轻描淡写
because it's, I'm basically saying this is an implication of the observations we've made in our lab. A second observation we've made in our lab around conflict also has to do with the psychological framing of the conflict. And it is, you can frame a discussion with your partner or even a disagreement with your partner as a specific problem or a global problem. And a lot of times we have flexibility in how we do that. And so, you know, if we're arguing about the toilet.
因为，我基本上是在说，这是我们实验室观察结果的一个推论。我们在实验室里围绕冲突得出的第二个观察结果，也与冲突的心理框架有关。那就是，你可以把与伴侣的讨论甚至与伴侣的分歧构建为一个具体的问题，或者一个全局性的问题。很多时候，我们在如何做到这一点上有很大的灵活性。所以，你知道，如果我们正在为马桶
seat. It could be, I want it raised and you want it lowered. Or it could be, I think that I've asked for something and you don't care enough to give it to me. So the fact that you aren't lowering the toilet seat is actually a sign that you don't love me. You don't care about me. You're not paying attention to me. Yeah.
盖争吵。可能是，我想要它竖起来，而你想要它放下来。或者可能是，我认为我已经提出了要求，而你并不在乎去满足我。所以你没有放马桶盖这一事实，实际上标志着你不爱我。你不在乎我。你没有注意到我。是的。
Well, that second one is more global. Right. And it's got a lot harder a problem to solve. Right. It's not a simple thing. It's applied to a much larger issue. Exactly. The happier couples, the couples that manage conflict more effectively are the couples that keep it specific.
好吧，第二个问题更具全局性。没错。而且这是一个很难解决的问题。没错。这不是一件简单的事情。它被应用到了一个大得多的问题上。完全正确。更幸福的夫妻、那些更有效地处理冲突的夫妻，是那些把问题保持在具体层面的夫妻。
Interesting. We have a dishwasher problem. It's a dishwasher problem. I'm not going to link this to, I'm not going to say that the problem is you're a selfish bastard. Because how am I going to solve that one? Let's just focus on the dishwasher. So another piece of advice that sort of comes out of this work is the more that you can keep your specific disagreement specific, the better for your relationship.
有趣。我们遇到了洗碗机的问题。这就是一个洗碗机的问题。我不会把这联系到，我不会说问题在于你是个自私的混蛋。因为我该怎么解决那个问题呢？让我们只专注于洗碗机。所以这种工作衍生出的另一个建议是，你越能把你的具体分歧保持在具体层面上，对你的关系就越好。
Containing the disagreements, containing conflict, is a good skill to practice. And shifting gears a bit, but you also have studied health and in relationships, not health of the relationship, but being healthy together as a couple. And you and your co-director wrote a book called Love Me Slender, which is very cute play on words. But can you explain the importance of, for couples, for being healthy, and how that helps a relationship? I mean, where is that correlation?
控制分歧，遏制冲突，是一项值得练习的好技能。换个话题，你还研究过健康与关系，不是关系的健康，而是作为伴侣一起保持健康。你和你的联合主任写了一本名为《爱我苗条》的书，这是一个非常可爱的双关语。但是你能解释一下，对于夫妻来说，保持健康的重要性，以及这如何帮助维护关系吗？我的意思是，这种关联在哪里？
Sure. That's a book. My co-director and collaborator is a guy named Tom Bradbury, who's a clinical psychologist at UCLA. And Tom, I wrote this book several years ago called Love Me Slender. And it came out of work that we had done on how couples support each other. And we'd studied for years. What makes couples more or less effective at supporting each other's goals? And it wasn't. until some years later that we asked, hey, what are those goals? What are they supporting each other doing? So we went back to, we had thousands of videotapes. And we went back and said, in those discussions where they're given an opportunity to support each other, what are they supporting each other with? And what we found out is that over half of the couples were asking each other for support about one issue. And that was health and fitness and diet and weight. In other words, their bodies. Couples, when they look to each other for support, half the time are saying, I want you to help me be healthier, either to lose weight or to eat better or to go to the gym more.
当然。那是一本书。我的联合主任兼合作者是一个名叫汤姆·布拉德利（Tom Bradbury）的人，他是加州大学洛杉矶分校的临床心理学家。汤姆和我几年前写了一本名为《爱我苗条》的书。它源于我们之前对伴侣如何互相支持所做的研究。我们研究多年的是：是什么让伴侣在支持彼此目标方面表现得更有效或更无效？直到几年后我们才问：嘿，这些目标是什么？他们在支持彼此做什么？所以我们回过头去，我们有数千小时的录像带。我们回过头来说，在那些让他们有机会互相支持的讨论中，他们在哪些方面互相支持？我们发现，超过一半的夫妻都在就一个问题向对方寻求支持。那就是健康、健身、饮食和体重。换句话说，就是他们的身体。夫妻在互相寻求支持时，有一半的时间都在说：我需要你帮我变得更健康，要么是减肥，要么是吃得更好，要么是去更多地去健身房。
So we looked at those tapes and we said, are couples doing a good job at helping each other do this thing that they really want help with? And what we noticed in the tapes was, on one hand, all these couples, we tend to study together, we tend to study. of younger couples who are pretty happy, they're committed to each other. These couples wanted to help each other. Like they wanted to, you look at me and you're like, I want to be healthy and I'm like, oh my God, I'm committed to you, we're going to be married for years. I want you to be healthier. I want to help you with your thing. And yet, it turned out to be a very hard thing to do. Providing effective support around health turned out to be fraught with difficulty. Let me give an example. If I say to you,
所以我们观看了那些录像带，然后我们说：夫妻在帮助对方做这件他们真正需要帮助的事情时，做得好吗？我们在录像带中注意到的是，一方面，所有这些夫妻，我们倾向于一起研究，我们倾向于研究那些比较年轻、相当幸福、对彼此做出承诺的夫妻。这些夫妻想要互相帮助。就像他们想要，你看著我，然后你觉得：我想要保持健康，而我就像：哦天哪，我对你作出了承诺，我们要结婚很多年。我希望你更健康。我想在你的事情上帮你的忙。然而，事实证明这是一件非常难做到的事情。围绕健康提供有效的支持，结果充满了困难。让我举个例子。如果我对你说：
do you think I look fat? Do you think I need to go to the gym? What's the helpful response? No, you look great. No, you're fine. Yeah. Now I don't go to the gym. I don't get healthy.
你觉得我看起来胖吗？你觉得我需要去健身房吗？有用的回应是什么？不，你看起来很好。不，你挺好的。是的。现在我不去健身房了。我没有变得健康。
Yeah. Here's another option. Yeah. Yeah, you are getting some weight. We should go to the gym. Yeah. Oh, yeah? How's that feel?
是的。这里有另一个选择。是的。是的，你确实长胖了。我们应该去健身房。是的。哦，是吗？感觉怎么样？
Yeah, right. It's tough. Yeah, it's tough. Yeah. It's tough. So that's why we wrote the book. We're like, oh, man, it's not easy. Even the couples who love each other.
是的，对吧。这很难。是的，这很难。是的，这很难。这就是我们写这本书的原因。我们想，哦，天哪，这并不容易。即使是那些相爱的夫妻。
It's not easy. So we started really looking into it. And what came out of the book was a couple big insights. And one is health is not individual. If you're in a relationship, there's no such thing as individual health. There's those just things, I'm just going to be healthier because so much of our lives are interdependent. You know, if you have a spouse or a coat, if you live with somebody, how many kitchens does the average house have? Calas has lots of bathrooms, only one kitchen.
这并不容易。所以我们开始深入研究。这本书带来的结果是几个深刻的见解。其中之一是：健康不是个人的。如果你处于一段关系中，根本没有所谓的个人健康。没有那种“我只是要变得更健康，因为我们生活中很大一部分是相互依存的”这种事。你知道，如果你有配偶，或者搭档，如果你和某人一起生活，普通房子有多少个厨房？卡拉斯（音译）有很多浴室，但只有一个厨房。
So you're going to be eating from the same fridge. So there's no way that you could just say, oh, I'm just going to have my fridge over here. You're going to have your fridge over here. That's just not how couples work. Yeah, cooking, meals and going to the grocery store and everything. Absolutely. These are social events.
所以你们将从同一个冰箱里拿食物。因此，你绝不可能说：哦，我要把我的冰箱放在这里。你要把你的冰箱放在那里。夫妻生活根本不是这样的。是的，烹饪、膳食、去杂货店购物以及一切。绝对是的。这些都是社交活动。
And so when somebody says, I want to eat differently, it affects their partner. And yet, that's not how diet books are written. That's not how diet books are written as if you make a change. You can't make a change that doesn't affect your partner. Yeah. So once you acknowledge that, you're like, wait a minute, I'm not going to be successful unless my partner's part of it. And that's a big part of the book. Another thing that we pointed out is that providing support is thorny because people want help, but they don't want bad help.
因此，当某人说“我想吃得不一样”时，这会影响到他们的伴侣。然而，减肥书并不是这样写的。减肥书并不是以“如果你做出改变”的方式编写的。你无法做出一个不影响你伴侣的改变。是的。所以一旦你承认这一点，你就会想：等一下，除非我的伴侣参与其中，否则我不会成功。这是这本书中很大的一部分。我们指出的另一件事是，提供支持是棘手的，因为人们需要帮助，但他们不想要糟糕的帮助。
And there's lots of help that is the kind of help we all can do without, as my childhood book said. So in the book, we have all sorts of examples from our tapes of couples that are trying to be helpful and kind of failing. And, you know, one way is exactly what you came up with, which is, no, honey, you look beautiful. You don't have to change the thing. Aren't I being loving? And I am being loving, but I'm not being helpful. Yes. So, you know, we talked about how you can thread that needle and say, hey, I love you.
正如我童年时读的书所说，有很多帮助都是我们不需要的帮助。所以在书中，我们从我们的录像带中找到了各种各样的夫妻例子，他们试图提供帮助，却有点失败。而且，你知道，其中一种方式正是你想出来的，那就是：不，亲爱的，你看起来很美。你不需要改变任何东西。我难道不够充满爱意吗？我确实充满了爱意，但我并没有提供有用的帮助。是的。所以，你知道，我们讨论了你如何能穿针引线地说：嘿，我爱你，
But did you say you want to do something? Well, if that's what you want to do, I'm going to help you. Not because I think you need to change, but because I hear you saying that you think you need to change, and I'm validating your goal. And we've seen couples do that. The example that we talk about in the book is a wife who says to the husband, and she says it with real sadness, I feel bad about my body and I don't feel attractive. And he says, oh, that's a big problem. It's a huge problem that you don't see the beautiful woman that I see when I look at you.
但你是不是说过你想做点什么？好吧，如果那是你想做的，我会帮你。不是因为我认为你需要改变，而是因为我听到你说你认为自己需要改变，我在确认你的目标。我们已经看到夫妻们这样做了。我们在书中讨论的例子是一个妻子对丈夫说，而且她是用一种真正的悲伤语气说的：我对自己的身体感到难过，我觉得自己没有吸引力。而丈夫说：哦，这是一个大问题。你看不到我眼中的那个美丽女人，这是一个巨大的问题。
That's terrible. What can we do about that together? How can we work on this problem? And that's a real deft move that he did. Because he was able to say, that's a serious problem. I'm totally on board with helping you solve that problem. At the same time, they were saying, I don't share the opinion.
这太糟糕了。我们能一起做点什么来解决这个问题？我们如何共同解决这个问题？这是他做出的一项非常高明的举动。因为他能够说：这是一个严重的问题。我完全支持你解决这个问题。与此同时，他们说：我不持有这种观点。
I don't. It's not a problem for me. And that's skillful. And so we wrote the book to sort of try to articulate that skill and share it with others. So that's what that book was about. Great. And you've, so switching gears at dating. Sure.
我没有。对我来说这不是个问题。这是很有技巧的。所以我们写这本书是为了试着阐明这种技巧并与他人分享。这就是那本书的内容。太棒了。而且你，那么转换话题到约会。当然。
Dating. You know, many people are looking for love on apps today, like Tinder, Bumble, OKCupid. And you and I spoke a bit about this. And you said that how we're dating? has changed. So we're not maybe necessarily meeting someone at a bar or at work as often, perhaps we're using apps. But you said how we're dating changed, but the actual dating, dating actions and dating itself has not changed. Can you explain that? Sure. It seems like I think it would people say, oh, it's totally different now than it was 20 years ago. You know, different people
约会。你知道，今天许多人都在应用程序上寻找爱情，比如 Tinder、Bumble、OKCupid。你和我讨论过这个问题。你说我们约会的方式已经改变了。所以我们可能不一定经常在酒吧或工作场所遇到某人，也许我们正在使用应用程序。但你说我们约会的方式改变了，然而实际的约会、约会行为和约会本身并没有改变。你能解释一下吗？当然。这似乎，我认为人们会说：哦，现在的环境和20年前完全不同了。你知道，不同的人
focus. You can focus on continuity and you can focus on change. And there's a lot that's changing and there's a lot that's staying the same. So what's changing? So as technology, what's changing in the domain of how do people find intimate partners? This is of interest to us. We study intimacy,
专注于。你可以关注连续性，也可以关注变化。有很多事情在变，也有很多事情保持不变。那么，什么在变呢？从科技来看，人们寻找亲密伴侣的领域发生了什么变化？这是我们感兴趣的。我们研究亲密关系，
so we're interested in how do people find intimate partners? And clearly, the technology available to do that is changing and is changing a lot. Whereas before, to find it to 20 years ago, 25 years ago, before we had smartphones, if you wanted to find into it partner, you had to go somewhere where people were likely to be, talk to a lot of people,
所以我们对人们如何寻找亲密伴侣感兴趣？显然，用于实现这一目标的科技正在发生变化，而且变化很大。而在过去，20年前，25年前，在我们拥有智能手机之前，如果你想找一个亲密伴侣，你必须去人们可能聚集的地方，和许多人交谈，
and hope that you find the available people. But nobody is wearing a T-shirt saying, I'm available. Some people might. Some people might, and good for those. But for the most part, they weren't. You'd have to sort of like say, hey, hi, are you interested? Like, no, I'm gay. Or no, I'm married.
并希望你能找到单身的人。但没有人穿着一件写着“我是单身”的T恤。有些人可能会。有些人可能会，这很好。但大多数情况下，他们不会。你得去搭讪，比如，嘿，嗨，你有兴趣吗？比如，不，我是同性恋。或者不，我已经结婚了。
Look at my ring or whatever. But now, with apps, you have a way of identifying people who are definitely available and local and willing to talk. All before you get in the room, that's amazingly convenient. That's for some people life altering. So, you know, if you were at a job or a circumstance where you meet a lot of people, maybe it doesn't make that much different. But if you're a modern person that works long hours, doesn't meet that many people at work, but you want to meet someone socially, how do you do it? You know, the old advice is join a club, and that's still good advice. But now there's a new way, which is I can actually go online and multiple apps will give me a long list of people who are interested in dating me, who are relatively my age, and who are within a short drive of my house.
看我的戒指什么的。但现在，有了应用程序，你有一种方法可以识别那些明确单身、在本地且愿意交谈的人。在你进入房间之前，这真是太方便了。对某些人来说，这是改变生活的事。所以，你知道，如果你在一份工作或某种情况下会遇到很多人，也许这没有太大区别。但如果你是一个现代人，工作时间很长，在工作场所遇不到太多人，但你想在社交场合结识某人，你该怎么做？你知道，古老的建议是加入一个俱乐部，这仍然是个好建议。但现在有了一种新方法，那就是我可以上网，多个应用程序会给我提供长长的一串名单，上面的人都有兴趣和我约会，年龄与我相仿，而且距离我家只有很短的车程。
That's astonishing. Yeah. That's incredible. It's a marvel of modern technology. Absolutely. It's as astonishing as the fact that I can order on Amazon something in the morning and it will be delivered to my house at night if I live in a major city. So this is incredible earth shattering. The convenience of it, that's the good news.
这太惊人了。是的。这太不可思议了。这是现代科技的一个奇迹。绝对是的。这就像我在大都市里，早能在亚马逊上订购某样东西，晚上就能送到我家一样令人惊叹。所以这是不可思议的、颠覆性的。它的便利性，这就是好消息。
The bad news is that some things haven't changed. And the establishing of romantic chemistry, well, that's not anything. that hasn't changed at all. And we haven't discovered any magic bullets for that. And now, there was a period where the dating apps were promising a magic bullet that didn't really exist. You had dating apps like chemistry.com and eharmony.com that were advertising very heavily with the promise that they had a magic algorithm that could select partners from the pool better than you could by yourself.
坏消息是，有些事情并没有改变。而建立浪漫的化学反应，嗯，这并没有什么改变。这完全没有改变。我们还没有发现任何灵丹妙药。现在，曾有一段时间，约会软件承诺过并不真正存在的灵丹妙药。你有像chemistry.com和eharmony.com这样的约会软件，它们进行了大量的广告宣传，承诺它们拥有一个神奇的算法，能够比你自己更好地从人群中挑选出伴侣。
They would say, we're going to ask you some questions, do a magic mathematical equation, and spit out people that you are guaranteed or at least have a high likelihood of matching with. That turned out to be snake oil. That has now been very well established to be bunk. But it was a persuasive idea.
他们会说，我们会问你一些问题，做一个神奇的数学方程式，然后吐出那些保证与你匹配或者至少匹配度很高的人。事实证明，那是江湖郎中卖的蛇油。现在这已经被广泛证实是胡扯。但这是一个具有说服力的想法。
It was an appealing idea. Lots of people paid a lot of money for it. And the reason they paid a lot of money for it is that there's something compelling. about the idea that if I give you a list of what I want in a partner, I want someone who votes like me, who likes Chinese food, who enjoys watching HBO limited series, and, you know, likes modern jazz. And if I find someone like that, great, I'm probably going to like that person.
这是一个很有吸引力的想法。很多人为此付出了大量的金钱。他们花大笔钱的原因是，有一个引人入胜的想法，那就是如果我列出我对伴侣的要求，我想要一个政见和我一样的人，喜欢中国菜，喜欢看HBO迷你剧，而且，你知道，喜欢现代爵士乐。如果我找到了这样的人，太棒了，我可能会喜欢这个人。
That assumption turns out to be false. Yeah, you said that it doesn't necessarily mean you'll hit it off just because you have the same interests. At all. Yeah. It doesn't. And the reason it doesn't is that we have. thousands of interests.
事实证明，这种假设是错误的。是的，你曾说过，仅仅因为你们有相同的兴趣，并不一定意味着你们会一拍即合。完全不会。是的。确实不会。原因在于我们有成千上万的兴趣。
And anyone you meet, it's not that if I share the right interests with you, I'm going to like you. It's the opposite. If I like you, we'll gravitate towards the interests that we have in common and will gravitate a way towards the interests that we don't have in common. Within a broad circle, I want someone who's nowadays, somebody who generally shares my politics. Nowadays, it's being of the opposite or being of the wrong political party is more stigmatized in dating than being of a different race or religion. Wow.
你遇到的任何人，并不是说如果我和你分享了正确的兴趣，我就会喜欢你。事实恰恰相反。如果我喜欢你，我们会倾向于我们共同拥有的兴趣，并避开我们没有共同点的兴趣。在一个广泛的圈子里，我希望现在有人能普遍分享我的政治立场。如今，在约会中，拥有对立的或错误的政党背景比拥有不同的种族或宗教信仰更受污名化。哇。
That's a new development. Yeah, how long has that been happening, do you think? In my lifetime, in the last 20 years, that kind of polarization, people have said, I wouldn't mind if my child came home with a partner of a different race, but I would never want my child to come home with a partner of a different party. Wow. So it's not super recent, but that's the same. It is super recent and it's decades, but not necessarily in the past like two or three years. It speaks to the divisions in the country. Yeah. But there's lots of people who share your political persuasion in the world. There's lots of people who share your religion. And within that,
这是一个新的发展。是的，你认为这种情况持续多久了？在我的一生中，在过去的20年里，这种两极分化，人们曾说，我不介意我的孩子带回来一个不同种族的伴侣，但我绝不愿意我的孩子带回来一个不同政党的伴侣。哇。所以这并不是超级新，但情况差不多。这确实非常新，持续了几十年，但不一定是在过去的两三年里。它说明了这个国家的裂痕。是的。但世界上有很多人与你的政治倾向相同。有很多人与你的宗教信仰相同。在此范围内，
it turns out that a list of things you like, a list of your hobbies, doesn't predict who you're like romantically. Because it turns out that romantic attraction is not about these sort of stable characteristics or interests. Romantic attraction has a lot more to do with behavior, interaction in the moment. Romantic attraction arises from how the exchange of behavior makes me feel. And if it makes me feel, you know, understood in the moment, and your capacity to behave in a way that makes you feel understood and excited and interested, has to do with what you do, not what foods you like to order in from.
事实证明，你喜欢的东西的清单，你的爱好清单，并不能预测你会在浪漫上喜欢谁。因为事实证明，浪漫吸引力与这些稳定的特征或兴趣无关。浪漫吸引力与行为、当下的互动有很大关系。浪漫吸引力源于行为的交流让我有什么感觉。如果它让我觉得，你知道，在当下被理解，而你表现得让你感到被理解、兴奋和感兴趣的能力，与你做什么有关，而不是与你喜欢叫什么外卖有关。
Once that feeling arises of romantic chemistry, then people look for, well, what do we have in common? Oh, we have this in common. Great, let's go do that thing. And people are complicated. We'll find something we have in common. So that's why, no matter how much you work on your profile, I wonder how many hours you study the other person's profile.
一旦浪漫化学反应的那种感觉出现，人们就会寻找，嗯，我们有什么共同点？哦，我们有这个共同点。太好了，我们去做那件事吧。而且人们很复杂。我们会找到我们共同的东西。这就是为什么，无论你在个人资料上花多少时间，我不知道你花了多少时间研究别人的个人资料。
You're not going to know what's going to happen when you meet until you meet. So dating apps can do something great and there's something they can't do. They can find people who are available. Which is helpful, obviously. Which is very helpful. It's amazing. But they can't tell you who you're going to like. Only interaction can tell you who you're going to like.
在你见面之前，你不会知道见面时会发生什么。所以约会软件可以做一些很棒的事情，也有它们做不到的事情。它们可以找到单身的人。这显然很有帮助。这非常有用。这太神奇了。但它们无法告诉你你会喜欢谁。只有互动才能告诉你你会喜欢谁。
So the apps are great. Use them, find people, and then get in front of them. So is that your advice to dating in 2018 and moving forward? That's just still to get away from your phone. Yes. Meet in person. Or even Skyping. Like there's, you know, this interaction, the face-to-face, the face-time, as it were.
所以这些应用程序很棒。使用它们，找到人，然后走到他们面前。这就是你对2018年及以后约会的建议吗？那仍然是远离你的手机。是的。亲自见面。甚至通过Skype。就像有，你知道，这种互动，面对面，可以说是FaceTime。
But I wouldn't spend that much time working out of profiles because profiles are not where it's happening. Great. Well, is there anything else you'd like to add? Any other research you wanted to talk about or other topics? Back to the policy issue. The things that I'm interested in pursuing are one of the other hidden ways, invisible ways that public policy affects intimacy. Because this is not something that gets discussed a lot. When we talk about public policies like health care, like tax increases or decreases, like the minimum way. age, all of those big public policy discussions are discussed in terms of, well, how will it affect income? How will it affect employment? How will it affect, you know, debt? The implication of some of the work we're doing lately is that all of those policies should affect intimacy as well. Intimacy, the decisions people make, should I get married, should I have a kid, am I satisfied
但我不会花那么多时间去完善个人资料，因为个人资料并不是事情发生的地方。太棒了。嗯，还有什么你想补充的吗？还有什么你想谈论的研究或其他话题？回到政策问题上。我所追求的事情之一是公共政策影响亲密关系的另一种隐藏的、无形的方式。因为这不是一个经常被讨论的话题。当我们谈论诸如医疗保健、增税或减税、最低工资年龄等公共政策时，所有这些重大的公共政策讨论都是从以下方面进行讨论的：它将如何影响收入？它将如何影响就业？它将如何影响债务？我们最近所做的一些工作的含义是，所有这些政策也应该影响亲密关系。亲密关系，人们做出的决定，我是不是该结婚，我是不是该要个孩子，我对你满意吗，
with you, are very much affected by the policy environment in which it takes place, in which these decisions take place. So one of the things that we're interested in pursuing is looking at the very private, intimate implications of these very public global policy changes. And so that's something that we're pursuing now, and we're something that we're pursuing now, and We're specifically doing analyses on what happens to marriage and divorce in states that raise the minimum wage. Interesting. You'd think that for poor couples, there might be an effect, and it seems like there is.
都深受其发生所在的政策环境的影响，这些决定正是在其中做出的。因此，我们感兴趣追求的事情之一，就是研究这些非常公开的全球政策变化所带来的非常私人的、亲密的影响。所以这是我们现在正在追求的事情，也是我们正在进行的事情，我们正在具体分析那些提高最低工资的州的结婚率和离婚率会发生什么变化。有趣。你可能会认为对于贫困夫妇来说可能会有影响，而且看起来确实有。
But that's really, you know, I shouldn't talk about that too much because that's still work we're working right now. That sounds fascinating. But the odd applications, it follows from the paper that we started talking about, which is if you want to help couples, you can help them by trying to teach them stuff. You can help poor couples by trying to teach them stuff. Or you can help them by making their lives easier. And it turns out that there's some evidence that if you make people's lives easier, intimacy improves even if you don't teach people anything. Huh, that's very interesting. So it's like, so it's like much, you think of relationship as just a small thing here, but it can obviously expand out more and to include a lot of other factors.
但那真的，你知道，我不应该谈论太多，因为那仍然是我们现在正在进行的工作。听起来很着迷。但奇怪的应用，它顺着我们开始讨论的那篇论文而来，也就是说如果你想帮助伴侣，你可以通过试着教他们一些东西来帮助他们。你可以通过试着教他们一些东西来帮助贫困伴侣。或者你可以通过让他们的生活更轻松来帮助他们。事实证明，有一些证据表明，如果你让人们的生活更轻松，即使你不教人们任何东西，亲密关系也会改善。哈，这非常有趣。所以这就像，所以这就像，你认为关系只是这里的一件小事，但它显然可以扩展得更大，并包含许多其他因素。
You've heard the expression that personal is political. the political turns out to be personal as well. And I actually just off the top of my head, I read an article recently about how the divorce rate from millennials is going down. Yeah. I mean, you know, you know, it's just new information shared, but, you know, basically it was saying people are choosing to marry later, you know, changing their habits in that way.
你听过“个人就是政治的”这种说法。事实证明，政治也是个人的。而且我其实就在脑海中，我最近读到了一篇文章，关于千禧一代的离婚率正在下降。是的。我的意思是，你知道，这只是分享的新信息，但基本上它是说人们选择晚婚，你知道，以那种方式改变他们的习惯。
So that's interesting as well. Do you have any thoughts on that? Yeah, absolutely. I read that same article. and the analysis showed very clearly that divorce rates are declining for millennials who went to college. Okay. It's not true of couples who didn't go to college. And so, and here's the point, is that nowadays, people who have access to education and have access to good careers are delaying marriage until their education and careers are in place.
所以这也是有趣的。你对此有什么看法吗？是的，绝对的。我读过同一篇文章，分析非常清楚地表明，上过大学的千禧一代的离婚率正在下降。好的。没上过大学的夫妇并非如此。所以，重点在这里，现在，受过教育和拥有良好职业的人正在推迟结婚，直到他们的教育和职业步入正轨。
So people who get married once their education and careers are in place have more stable marriages. Makes perfect sense. People who don't go to college are marrying less but marrying earlier. And when they marry, they don't have careers in place, then their lives are going to be harder. And they struggle and their marriages struggle too. Makes perfect sense. That's really fascinating. Interesting.
因此，一旦教育和职业步入正轨才结婚的人拥有更稳定的婚姻。完全说得通。没上过大学的人结婚较少，但结婚较早。当他们结婚时，他们没有稳定的职业，那么他们的生活将会更艰难。他们会挣扎，他们的婚姻也会挣扎。完全说得通。这真的很迷人。有趣。
I'm interesting to see what comes of that and more studies are done or what news comes that as we move forward. Absolutely. I'm very interested in as well. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Carney. It's been a really fascinating talk. Caitlin, thank you for having me. I'll have this chat with you any time. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts like APA journals dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also visit at speakingof psychology.org to find more episodes and to view resources on the topics we
我很想看看这会带来什么结果，以及未来会开展更多研究或出现什么新闻。绝对的。我也非常感兴趣。非常感谢你加入我们，卡尼博士。这是一次非常迷人的谈话。凯特琳，谢谢你邀请我。我随时都乐意与你进行这样的聊天。“心理学之谈”是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包含其他精彩的播客，例如APA期刊关于最新和最令人兴奋的心理学研究的对话，以及关于心理学实践的进展说明。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们的播客。你也可以访问speakingof psychology.org来查找更多剧集并查看我们讨论的主题的资源。
discuss. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna, for the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是你的主持人凯特琳·卢娜，代表美国心理学会。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。